البحر
بيضحك
لي وانا
نازله عامله
الاولى البحر
بيضحك
ليه وانا نازله
الدعم ل
و البحر
بيضحك ليه ليه ليه وانا نازله الد عامله
الاول بيني وبينك سور ورا
صور وانا ل
مارد وال
عصفور بيني وبينك صور ورا صور
وانا لا
مارت ولا
عصفور في ايدي عود
والعود
مقصود في ايدي عود اول
وجسور وصبحت
انا في العشق مثل والبحر
بيضحك ليه
وانا
نازله عامله الاولى معانا البحر
بضحك ليه ليه ليه وانا
نازله عامله
الاول
قول لنا فخار هدنا وي
بتقول
حكاوي
وغناوي قل لنا فخار
ناوي بتقول
حكاوي
وغناوي
يا ق الز انا
ناوي مشرب ولو في الميه عسل والبحر
بيضحك
ليه على ناس
ل عامله
الاولى
يلا البحر بيضحك
ليه وانا نازله قد عمله
الاولل البحر
بيضحك
ليه وانا
زمله
الاول
رغم اللي فات انا البطل جوه الف
رغم
الاها مش هموت ناقص
حلو رغم اللي فات انا البطل جو
الفيل رغم
الهات مش هموت ناقص
حلم رامي
ظروف من فوق
كتا
في اتحدى
خوفي يا دنيا
خافي انا
انا قد
الحياه انا قد
الحياه
قادر اعيش واكسر خوفي في
مرايتي ما
يهمنيش ما انا لسه بطل
حكايتي قادر اعيش واك صر
خوفي في
مريتي ما
يهمنيش ما انا لسه بطل
حكايتي
بميت
ظروفي منفوق
كتافي
اتحدى
خوفي يا دنيا
خافي انا انا قد
الحياه انا قد
الحياه
او
او انا قد
الحياه
انا قد
الحياه انا قد
الحياه انا
الحياه
uh
الساعه سبعه عصافير تزقزق الشمس تشرق وهو
ساده وعم سيد شيخ حرتنا بس في ايده حافته
غدا الساعه سعه عصافير تزقزق الشمس تشر
واهو سد وعم سيد شيخ حرتنا بس في ايده حفه
غده اطفال شوارع ام
المصانع شاب جمعه ودكتور
ولاده اطفال شوارع
عمال مصانع وشاب جمعه ودكتور
ولاد خرج تجاره بيبيع جرائد عسكري i ب
be
الكل رايح على اكل اعيشه وانا اللي قاعد
حزين في بطي مش لاقي فرش قرشين زياده مش
لاقي فرش
قرشين زياده مش لاقي فرش و قرشين زياده
مش
يفلش قرش
زياده
في شوارع ا
المصانع شاب جمع ودكتور
ولاده اطفال شوارع
عمال مصانع وشب جمع ودكتور
ولاده خرج تجاره بي بيع جرائد عسكري ب
ب في كل مكان انا
وانت نا كم ذكره
سب في درج سنين كتير
فاتت حاجات منك حاجه مني في كل مكان انا
وانت لنا كم ذكرى
متساب في درج سنين كتير فاتت حاجات منك
حاجات مني سجايري جنب
مكياجك
والولاعه
والجاكت وقم الحبر
لسه
بيحضن الاوراق
ويكتب اسمك الشفاف وانا
مشتاق
هنا يحبن الاوراق
واكتب اسمك الشفاف وانا مشتاق
هنا
هي
انت
انت زمان
كنتي
بعكسك من ورا
الشباك وانا قاعد في
بلكونتي سم الاحلام انت زمان
كنتي بعكسك من ورا الشباك وانا قاعد في
بلاك
ونتي برسم
الاحلام وبحطن الاوراق وبكتب اسمك الشفاف
وانا
مشتاك هنا
وبحضن الاوراق
وبكتب اسمك الشفاف وانا
مشتاق هنا
هي
وبحضن الاوراق
وبكتب اسمك الشفاف وانا
مشتاق هنا هي
وبحضن الاوراق
وبكتب اسمك الشفاف وانا
مشتاق
هنا
ها
ا
فوق
السبع
سماوات على العرش
استوى اخترنا من
الكائنات وعايزنا نفضل
سوات فوق
السبع
سماوات
على العرش
استوى اخترنا من
الكائنات وعايزنا نفضل
سوا
هي
خلق البشر الوان وخلق احنا
مختلفين يجمعنا سوا
الانسان قبل ما يجمعنا الدين خلق البشر
الوان وخلقنا
مختلفين يجمعنا سوا
الانسان قبل ما يجمعنا
الدين
differ love is in me and
you
exs no
col no distance love is in me and
you ب ا ا تك ما تبصليش من بشرط من غير
عقيده
والتماس خليني جنبك هقك لا هكون وراك ولا
هسبك بلكره وطن الاغبياء
بني ادم عيش اد ميتك ما تبصليش في بشرتك
من غير ده
وانتماء خليني جنبك الحق لا هكون وراك ولا
هسبقك بالكره وطني الاغبياء
خلق البشر الوان وخلقنا
مختلفين يجمعنا سوا
الانسان قبل ما يجمعنا تين خلق البشر
الوان وخلقنا
مختلفين يجمعنا سوا
الانسان قبل ما يجمعنا
لا البشر قل و
مختلفي خلق البشر
قل
وخبل في
مع سوا
الانسان فوق السبع
سماوات على الرش
يا عبد
العزيز بدشت كتير هدايا الراجع وم لقيتهوش
دورت في كل هديه كتير بالطول والعرض وقلبت
الشنطه كمان على
الارض ولقيت دبله وجبات
وكروت مقسوم وصور وقلوب
ولقيت دبله وجوابات
وكروت وجنيه مقسوم وصور
وقلوب لكن برضو ناقص
دبدوب لكن برضو ناقص
دبدوب نا
اسبو نا
اسبو
اسمو
نا كل اللي في قلب الشنطه معايا في
ستنظر وبجد الشنطه بدون دبدوب مالهاش منظر
كل الجوابات ممكن يكتبها حبيب غيري
والدبله خلاص موضوع اتشال من تفكيري وقف
شنطه كل حبيب وحبيبه
هتلقي حاجات منهم
واكتر
واهد اشمع ودمع وفرح وامل
ساكن ممكن
لكن مش كل حبيب بيجي
بدبدوب مش كل حبيب بيجي
بدبدوب ناقص
دبدو ناقص
دبتو ص بتتو يا ليل يا
ما
اس
لما كنت بغير لما اعرف انه بندير عينك
وبحس ساعتها كانه حرس بيني وبينك واتخيل
انه ساعتها خلاص قرب منك وبديك عليه
وعينيكي
عليه اجري واطلع صورتك ك
وانده والله يا روحي انا اللي
شرير وسنين بتفوت وسنين
بتطور وفي لحظه خلاص يجمعنا
كلام احلام ودع
بدوب موت احلام ويضيع
دبدوب ناقص
دبدوب ص
نبنوب ص
قول يا
سعد قلب الطيب مش قادر ينسى سنين
فاتت مش قادر ينس حكايه حب ويقول ماتت
جايلك من تاني بحلم
جديدك وفي ايده ل
ومواعيد ومعاد ابنا وجوابات و
كروب وجنيه مقسوم وصور
وقلوب ومعاد ب لو جوابت
وكروب وني مقسوم وصور
وقلوب
قلك علشان خاطري خلي
الدبدوب خلي
الدبدوب مش نايز
دبدو
زفوز